today we're going to talk about stoicism
which is a philosophy and sort of twin
entrant connected themes of leadership
and leadership and entrepreneurship what
I want to do to begin with is start out
by asking you questions so just you know
raise your hands if you're familiar with
these these sorts of things who here
would say they know something that's
stoic philosophy
nobody says brand-new crowd okay so
nobody knows who say
Epictetus is anybody heard of that
betina's before precipitous Cato the
younger none of these is hero's own
momentum okay so let me ask a different
set of questions who here regularly
reads Business Insider business ethics
class right you guys want to be
connected with businesses in some way
you want to be entrepreneurs that's what
you have to read how about The Economist
does anybody here read The Economist or
Harvard Business Review sort of much
reading or for that sort of thing
what about the more entrepreneurial
oriented things like Inc and if you read
Inc to ask company all sorts of
publications why why would I bring those
up do you think what would be my motive
and I'm doing a little polling
any guesses well if if you read them
well you're gonna find is that what you
should probably do is go to their
websites I'll then just do a search and
search for stone or stoicism and you're
gonna see probably dozens of articles
kind of go what why are people
interested in ancient Greek philosophy
all of a sudden like in the last ten
years or so there's a lot of articles
discussing modern interest and
adaptations of stoicism let's ask about
another thing who here thinks about or
views in a good sense
resiliency I got a few people
how about productivity what a good thing
bad thing something you think about it
all if you're a business you think about
it right accountability leadership
that's something that resonates with you
creativity creative types in here so in
a lot to count a lot of context these
are just buzzwords these are things that
people say and they only talk about
innovation innovation that's great you
know it's good TED talk about that a lot
of that stuff turns out to be kind of
fluff when you start poking and prodding
at it and then there's also a great
literature out there about well how do
you in fact cause innovation how do you
hold people accountable for things and
what you're gonna find more often than
not is there's some sort of theory
driving this and you have a choice of
which theories you're going to use these
things can mean a lot more people who
are successful leaders or successful
entrepreneurs have usually not only
thought about these things and talked
about these things they've usually
researched them a good bit they spent
quite a bit of time and so the question
that you should ask yourself as students
is well what are they drawing what is
their secret sauce that they have
that you don't yet have what do you need
to be studying what do you need to be
reading what do you need to be thinking
about if you want to be successful if
you want to model yourself after these
people who actually make a living and
change the world and do interesting
things usually on somebody else's
expense account so in the last 15 years
strangely enough for again somebody like
me who's among other things an academic
philosopher a lot of this has been
driven by interest in stoicism in
ancient Greek stoic philosophy and so
what I'm going to do first here in this
talk is discuss this growing popularity
and then bring up a key decision that
you'd have to make and then I want to
introduce you to just a few keys to make
ideas that I think would be particularly
important in a business setting whether
you're talking about leadership and
management or you're talking about
entrepreneurship you know going off on
your own there's a lot of intersection
between the two of them of course and
there's plenty of time for Q&A and
discussion at the end hopefully but I
also will have built in some places and
I encourage you to ask questions I'm
very happy to explore them with you
that's part of what makes talks fun so
let's talk about this growing popularity
of stoic philosophy and I want to start
by making a distinction right at the
back when you when you hear this word
stoicism oftentimes that's associated
with you know being emotionless having a
job and just sticking to it whether
people are you know making it difficult
for you or not just not caring
whatsoever
that's not exactly what stoicism means
that that's sort of this lowercase s
stoicism but that's not what what we're
talking about here one of the things
that you probably want to know about if
you know all you've got right now is why
I say so that stoicism is quite popular
well how popular is it or how do we
measure that what are the indexes of
that so there was a big gathering of
Stoics the largest gathering ever
historically just in New York City a few
weeks ago called stoic on
and they had some of the you know
important speakers in the literature
that's out there and the websites that
are out there I did a workshop myself on
stoicism and anger got to enjoy some
really great discussions with people
that was about 300 or so 330 I think not
a huge crowd but for the academic crowd
that that's pretty big but you might say
that's not too much look around on the
web you're gonna find that there's
meetups all over the world for people
who are interested in stoicism most of
them are not students most of them are
actually working professionals that are
finding that this this is enhancing
their life and enhancing their their
work in some way
stoicism reddit is about 37,000 regular
users the stoicism Facebook group has
about 16,000 there's some other groups
as well that are smaller but this shows
you that there is quite a huge online
presence and you might say well that's
that's nice but that's like a clump you
know it's a hot people have you know
there's probably more people interested
in the walking-dead Facebook groups or
things like that right I don't know what
the stance of because I don't look it up
because I quit watching it a while ago
there's probably some strong feelings
about that if there's anybody who
watches it so what about other ways of
thinking about it stoicism stoic
philosophy is being studied by people in
the military by officers by enlisted
people both the Army and the Navy have
had initiatives connected with it in one
way or another is studied by people in
in coaching and sports it's used to
increase performance in that it's
studied by people in business settings
corporate settings investors
entrepreneurs there are stoic
politicians believe it or not not a lot
of them but there are a few people who
self-identify in Stoics and are mayors
of different places also athletes on
their own events
this people in the service industry have
found it quite useful prisoners people
in prisons have been using stoicism to
understand things and some examples
the Seahawks coach it had is his players
actually do workshops in stoicism this
is before this season would be more of a
recommendation last year this year but
Pete Carroll is somebody who's quite
interested in stoicism
I'm Tim Ferriss an investor credit
stoicism Bryan Holaday who spoke at
Stough account is one of the featured
speakers Marc major marketer some of you
may know him from that work some of you
may know him from some of his books
these are all examples of the people who
were using stoic philosophy in their
work it's also used in a number of
psychotherapeutic approaches cognitive
behavior therapy rational emotive
behavior therapy come out of stoic
philosophy in one way or another so in a
way that's this is all kind of
surprising but in a way it's not that
surprising for two reasons one is when
stoicism as we're gonna look at it has a
lot to say to all these people about a
lot of different issues the other thing
is stomachs themselves were involved in
leadership they were also arguably
involved in at least the ancient
equivalent of entrepreneurship so if you
if you look at some of these you know
big names in the movement you know one
guy who clearly was involved in
leadership though they need to heard
Marcus Aurelius Roman Emperor probably
don't from gladiator but absolutely
mothers he wrote a book called the
meditations those are you know not he
didn't write it for publication just
jotted down his thoughts because he was
a stoic and he was in charge of a good
portion of the known world
at the time and he used stoicism to be
one of the few good Roman emperors one
of the few good leaders that they had
Zeno the founder of the school was
courted by the king of Macedon who
wanted him to be sort of a court
philosopher he thought he had something
to offer Cato the younger was a leader
in the Roman Civil War he wound up on
the side that lost unfortunately for him
but he provided an example of what stoic
leadership might be like Seneca I've
been a member of Seneca the the
philosopher the writer he tried to
advise the Emperor Nero if you know
anything about Nero you know he really
wasn't advisable that was losing
situations but he probably did curb some
of Nero's excesses
Epictetus great stoic philosopher was
visited by the Roman Emperor Hadrian
presumably gave him some advice so
there's a lot of background for Stoics
in leadership and one of the questions
we should ask ourselves that and we'll
do a little Q&A after after this is what
should we make of this current interest
is this sort of a flash in the pan kind
of thing or is this worth paying
attention to so you know whenever you
see people being attracted to some
ancient form of thought you should take
a close look at it because usually those
things have been taught and then you
know they go through revivals because
there's actually something there worth
looking at but what is there what's
worth looking at what what are these
people deriving from it what are they
getting out of it and why so I think
it's good to distinguish a couple
different approaches and this doesn't
work just for stoicism this works for
people that are into Buddhism people
that are you know adapting yoga people
that are you know and whatever it is
that you want that has some sort of you
know ancient tradition or philosophical
background and people are using it in a
business setting so there is the more
superficial appropriations
these things and on the one side and
then there's the more you know let's
call it profound and integrated
approaches to these things and then
there's everything in the day so what
would be really superficial books of
cults you know a little Facebook posts
that say here's what you know Epictetus
said and you could calendar that his
like you know 365 little quotes you look
at it the morning so okay now I'm ready
to face the day and that pixie dust a
lot of cool stuff and so did Marcus
Aurelius but so did everybody else under
the Sun so I don't think that's
particularly important but people do
that there's also if you look at the
Articles that are out there like in the
game in Forbes they're going to talk
about stoicism and its use in life hacks
you guys familiar with this term like
that should be right because that's your
generation that's being targeted with
all this time not so much my and so
they'll talk about toolkits and this is
kind of superficial too but at least
does draw on actual stoic ideas and
Stoics a lot of useful practices that
could be turned into things to increase
your productivity or help you out in
dealing with clients or help you not
lose it in talking to your employees all
things that could be quite useful in a
business setting there's a lot of talk
about stoicism as an operating system
what is an operating system you know
because I how many of you who doesn't
have a smartphone in here anybody there
do you all have a smartphone right so
mine operates on iOS what's the other
main one on Android right now there
might be something else what does an
operating system do phone will work
without it right what does it do
you're thinking about mean processes and
information translate displays okay
without it you can't do anything right
does the operating system actually
decide anything important for you
it shouldn't I mean that's one of my
views with the Apple as they keep
changing stuff and I don't like change
so yeah I don't like when the display
looks different I'm like who authorized
them yeah you know now we don't have
functionality anymore
that's me complaining about the
operating system being more than just an
operating system if we look at stoicism
as an operating system it would be some
well that's the philosophy and then
whatever you do with that that's up to
you
so you know if you're doing sports stuff
you got this stuff that you're using if
you're in a business setting over here
like a corporate setting traditional you
know hierarchical stuff if you're no
more agile entrepreneurial mindset
you're doing this stuff over here it all
be you know just drawn whatever works
for you that's using stoicism again and
I think that may be in fact the way a
lot of people look at it it can also be
understood on the other side as a way in
life as a sort of substantive set of
commitments and you know where you if
you got interested in this sort of thing
would fit on that spectrum that would be
up to you I'm going to try to make an
argument for you that stoicism works
better for all the stuff that people
want it for when you're actually tied in
with the more substantive commitments
that it's Stoicism light isn't quite as
effective as you know the full package
you could say in business terms what am
i doing upselling right you guys are
familiar with that term should be
anybody in sales well you know what I'm
selling is right what are you upselling
in a restaurant yeah and so in a way I'm
upselling you but I'm selling you for
something that I think it's
fundamentally good for you
drinks not quite the same okay so
there's two things I want to point out
about this so the more stoicism is
reduced to isolated closer techniques
the less authentically stoic it is and
we need to be used in ways that are
fundamentally at odds with what the
Stoics teach that's a possibility
right the other question that you have
to ask and I think this is a really
legitimate question especially for you
college students we're very busy
some of you have jobs all of you have
lives I hope you know college doesn't
consume you completely you would have to
ask yourself okay so there's one more
thing that I need to study how much time
would I need to put into this in order
to get something out of it that's a real
legitimate question and we'll maybe talk
about that more towards the end my
suggestion is that we can probably
figure some of this out by going through
some of the key stoic ideas and so we'll
hit on some of those key ideas but but
any questions at this point about what
the popularity of stoicism this notion
of it being you know stoicism light over
here or you know stoicism regular over
here and does it make sense to you
anybody lost in the weeds at this point
okay well let's go on then because I
don't have a lot of time so one key idea
that the Stoics have that I think is
being used by a lot of people in
entrepreneurial and leadership contexts
is this fundamental distinction between
what's in our power and what's not in
our power
what's in our control and what's not in
our control the stomachs are not the
only people who talk about this there's
other you know wisdom traditions like
Buddhism that talks about this as well
right
but the Stoics make it absolutely
central and it's a way of putting
matters into perspective in two
different ways one is figuring out well
what really is in our control and what
isn't in our control the other is
figuring out how does that affect
matters of value go
bad right wrong how we should make our
decisions where we should make our
priorities so the stomach's say that
what's in our power are these things our
thoughts our opinions our desires and
our aversions our choices and our
refusal our emotions and how we respond
to what appears to us those are the
things that are fundamentally in our
power in our control we don't control
the outside world we try to control
parts of it right again I use this knife
phone as an example because I have a
love-hate relationship with this piece
of technology I just upgraded to the new
operating system which I don't like it
because I had some change and you know
give me another six months and I'll like
that I won't like it actually after it
but you know the phone one of the things
that's different is the Maps function it
doesn't come up right away takes longer
to come up right now and it doesn't do
quite what I like it to do in the past
well this was totally outside of my
control Apple doesn't care at all what I
think they at one time they were the in
the industry that actually did now
they're a giant we're all you know tiny
little people to them apples gonna do
what Apple's going to do much like the
weather right if if you get upset
because it's raining on you you've got a
problem right you're getting upset over
something you have no control whatsoever
yeah the economy you don't have a lot of
control over that you control this tiny
tiny tiny little part of it but you
don't control much of it and you know
one of the things that besides that that
fall out of our control other people's
thoughts or feelings or choices wealth
property reputation now that's not to
say that you can't you know take
precautions that you should spend your
money foolishly or you shouldn't take
care of your body or if you've got a
house you should never
like you know pay the taxes or or take
care of it or anything like that but you
can you can do that and your house can
flood right you can have the best
business plan in the world and every
investor can still say nope not
interested many great authors and farm
their books around to you know 10 20
sometimes 50 publishing houses all of
them turned them down before somebody
find they said yes some of them after
the author's died so there's a lot of
things that are outside of our control
and why does this matter well it's not
just enough to get it straight but
what's actually in our control and
what's not in our control it matters
because that's where we think that our
are good lies and our bad lies and so
what the Stoics tell us is that what's
really good for us or bad for us is what
is in our control it's in our
personality it's in the parts that we
can control like for example I may not
like the weather I may walk across
campus and get rained on or maybe it
heals right there is there is the
hailstorm out here sometimes held like
this big you could get by that that
hurts right so hail hits me now I didn't
control whether I feel physical pain but
I do control over how I react I shaped
my fist at the sky yeah stupid weather
you know I'm just making myself more
upset right unnecessarily so does it fix
anything for me to do that not at all
now think about something that's not
quite so silly you have to do a
performance review your employee and
you're not looking forward because
you've got to give them some bad news
which is that their performance is
subpar and unless you really like firing
people or you know shooting people most
people don't like that right even most
of those business types don't like
having to tell people things like that
now imagine you've got to tell somebody
look we're gonna have to let you go
pretty soon if you don't fix things here
how does it usually react do they do
they take that well some people
you're experienced know who do they
usually take it out of date they say oh
well I'm gonna go talk to the boss who
is telling you this stuff no they go
after you right you're being unfair
well you don't control that person well
you do control is your own reactions to
them how do you how do you think about
the situation whether you allow it to
get to you what's going to be more
effective you getting upset and arguing
with them
or are you keeping your cool yeah I mean
there would imagine some far-fetched
situation in which the opposite is the
case but in most cases keeping their
cool right so it's it's important to be
able to learn this distinction and then
practice it and apply it over and over
and if you do that what you find over
time is that gradually you're less and
less bothered by things now how does
that I'll hear this how does that affect
your own productivity how does it affect
your own ability to perform if you're
not as bothered by the little stuff by
the stuff that you don't actually have
any control what does that do for you
yeah it gives you focus so you can see
what entrepreneurs would be attracted to
this sort of thing let's well actually
we have built in a little bit of time
any any questions about this particular
aspect does this make sense to you
this distinguishing what's in your
control what's not in your control any
any like objections that come to your
mind are the things that you say yeah
we control those it's a very good
question yeah yeah
so our motivations you're talking about
are serve our structure of motivations
which is often a whole bunch of all
mixed up together desires and emotions
and we're usually not sure where some of
them may have come from like our culture
some may have come from mom and dad and
their expectations some may have come
from you know meeting a circumstance and
failing and then being like I'm never
going to fail again
the Stoics aren't saying that we could
like snap our fingers and then suddenly
go from you know having one set of
desires to another set what they are
saying is that we we are able to tinker
around with the mechanics of it right
it's very like working on a complex
system where well let's see what happens
when we pull this thing out does that
make anything better in the system or
not we can do that and it takes time to
do it's not something like I said that
you can you know immediately decide like
if I for example yeah I didn't get this
sighs by not eating you know more food
than I should so I should exercise more
and eat smaller portions right that
might happen you know but I can't like
you know snap my fingers and then
suddenly drop you know 50 pounds and be
exercising I have to build that up over
time it's cabins what I can do is look
at well why do i why do i or one of the
killers for me is watching TV at night
to relax and then having a snack before
death right stupid and nobody should do
that at all even people who are in good
shape like you are right shouldn't do
that it's a bad habit to get into now I
can look at why do I desire that and it
probably has something to do with like I
feel like I'm entitled to because I put
in I didn't put in like 14 to 16 hour
work days usually so you know it's a I'm
entitled well maybe maybe I'm not maybe
that's an irrational thought on my part
that's
productive and this is just one example
we can do this with lots of other things
and so that someone goes to dressing
that that big structure of motivation
thing you can't be kicking a bird's eye
picture of all of it at once you know
you have to kind of probe at it over
time but the other cool thing that I'll
tell you about the Stoics is they stress
some of you having to go to a
psychiatrist to figure all this out for
you you workout it yourself it's kind of
a DIY project using some of the
techniques that you learned from them
hopefully you know don't miss apply
there are there are practitioners out
there but it is something where if
you're not dependent on a class of
experts to to carry it all out which is
kind of nice all right let's let's talk
about another issue that's what this
goes to something very close to this
unproductive emotions and desires so the
Stoics
the Stoics thought that emotions always
involve some sort of judgment they're
not just feelings that we have they
they're they're wings of our thinking
something about the world so if I get
angry for example yeah that's somebody
who are getting a bit of pride that's
different than being sad that's
different than being happy that's
different than being afraid when I get
angry what's going on
what sort of judgment am I making think
thinking when you get angry like I get
angry at my phone for not now I'm now
instead of like during the the way of
getting into it before we do to slide
across I've got the old habits built up
now you got to do something different
that's like 30 times a day I'm getting
irritated with my phones is stupid
really stupid that's right but I'm
working it what do you what happens when
you can hear it what judgment are you
making
things unfair yeah that's that's core to
it somebody did something and it was
wrong and it wasn't the kind of wrong
thing that could have like balanced out
something wrong somewhere else it's
unfair it shouldn't be happening to me
now what else is included because that
could just make you sad right
oh it's unfair what was made always
happens to be sort of depressive thing
when you get angry you're energized
what are you energized to do you're like
okay so now when you're yelling or
screaming what are you what are you
trying to do you try to express yourself
that you're also trying to what else
okay so you're directing it at something
and we often talk about like trying to
get revenge or retribution or get the
other person admit that they're wrong
that's what is involved in anger all of
that is built into that feeling that you
feel like me I feel here where you guys
feel it all that is built into it now if
you can analyze that you can keep
yourself from being taken off balance by
it you could say well okay I feel angry
they don't need to act on it sometimes
you can keep your soft feeling is angry
the Stoics that anger wasn't a good
thing they they in fact thought that a
lot of emotions get in our way would
things like that get in your way in a
business context yeah is it
unprofessional to lose your temper for
example I mean there are some
professions I guess where it might be
okay you know being a drill sergeant but
that's a pretty limited field
right and you can't get away with that
sort of thing so there's a lot of
emotions and desires that we want to
develop some insight instead we want to
be able to change
stoicism offers us you might say some
mechanics for doing it it's very similar
how many of you are familiar with the
lid
out there on emotional intelligence
anybody now that's an interesting walk
by Daniel Goleman because it actually
begins with a quote by a philosopher by
Aristotle
but the Stoics were doing the same sort
of work they were interested in figuring
out how we can understand our emotions
how we can manage them how we can
identify and respond to other people's
emotions so like if you get angry at me
quite often when somebody gets angry at
us our response is either to feel fear
or to feel anger in response or
sometimes depression if you're like a
troll happiness and it could be
extremely counterproductive if somebody
that lets say you're angry at me and
you've got a real reason to be angry at
me I'm your boss I gave the promotion to
her even though you have you know you've
been doing more work and you've been
there longer that's a legitimate reason
I would say it's a beats if it could be
angry and probably even to express anger
if I just get angry at you and now dig
my heels in I'm probably doing something
that's not good for the firm not good
for me not good for you our relation not
good for the customers there's a whole
bunch of the facts that cascade outward
when we don't manage our emotions well
and when we don't understand why other
people feel their emotions so the Stoics
think that this is particularly
important I'll give you an example
people-pleasing
what is you guys familiar with this term
what is people are going to do people
I'm not going to ask you to raise your
hand like what you did
what does people please use that term
oh there's the key you don't really want
to you don't think it's a good thing but
you do it anyway why do we do that okay
so that's a great example of what the
Stoics call an aversion you're averse to
conflict or however else you want to put
it enemy may also be seeking the
approval of that person eventually why
does that turn into a problem in a
business context let's say you're an
entrepreneur you're starting a company
your clients want a lot out of you
what's going to happen to your
people-pleaser you'll get burnt out
you may over promise and not not be able
to deliver because people are always
trying to push for a little bit more so
you know if you can understand the
dynamic behind it you can recognize that
this is not good for you and you can
decide to take some sort of action in
that case another key idea that's
related to this is resiliency what do we
mean by a resiliency what is that's a
common word these days sometimes we feel
like the word grit instead near those
things what do you think other than
you're being asked to do more with yeah
that's a really good way to put it
there's two things you're talking about
there so having the knowledge remain
operative you could say within within
your because you often know what we're
supposed to do talk to it right but
keeping that knowledge operative and
then not not just checking out because a
common response to feeling like well
well I just can't I can't do it you know
so stoicism counsels us first of all by
doing stoic practice people become more
resilient a lot of it there's actually a
lot in
studies out there that show that this
sort of activity does help with that but
another thing we can do that's
particularly helpful is we can't look at
setbacks or obstacles as something other
than them as opportunities as places
where we can grow we can figure out what
we need to do you know things that we
often look at as being just bad often
can be looked at in another perspective
because the first initial perspective is
not the only way we can look at it
that's what a store calls an appearance
an appearance that is is irritating or
troubling we can step back from them
because well what's actually going on
here you know then this also doesn't
mean that we have to pretend that things
are better than they are we don't have
to pretend like people are at sometimes
jurors or opportunists or even out to
get us we don't have to say that people
don't do things that are bad or
irrational or counterproductive but we
don't have to allow ourselves to be
negatively affected in our core in our
emotions and our thoughts by those even
if they do affect us financially or even
in terms of health getting angry at
people or not here your cortisol levels
kind of go through the roof and it
affects your body in certain ways but
you you can eventually develop some sort
of control over that what would be an
example of that what do you think the
you know when you bring a product out if
you had this was given it's sort of a
number how many what percentage of the
products that are brought out actually
Macon's with them like say the first
year or so it's pretty small right now
if you're an entrepreneur you should
imagine that you're probably going to
fail a lot you're not going to be a
out-of-the-park success the first time I
mean you could it's pretty pretty rare
and those who usually are don't follow
it up with another
so how can you look at a situation like
that I mean it's what happens when you
do that you invest a lot of your time
and your reputation into that product
it's sort of your baby right Plato says
this by the way way back in ancient
Greece business people when they have
products they look at those products as
they're their children and it's just
like somebody talking bad about your
your son or your daughter people don't
like that and it makes you feel really
upset how can you look at the situation
differently as an opportunity rather
than is how the world is screwing you
over and being ungrateful to you for
offering this wonderful product well
here's one example you could say well I
think I actually need to do some market
research and figure out why this didn't
sell what was it about my product that
the customers didn't actually like and
then would that help you for going out
to the next product
you can only do that if you're actually
willing to step back right that's what
resiliency in part consistent let's talk
about something else now so I'm talking
about things that would like improve
your performance as an entrepreneur or
as a leader let's talk now about moving
from what we could call the stoic F
those to the stoic ethics so the Stoics
are pretty uncompromising this is where
we're talking about are you just doing
life hacks or are you actually buying
the full package and I said I was going
to try to upsell you a little bit and
I'm not going to be a really great
salesman at this point because I'm going
to talk about how hard the stoic ethics
actually hurts to live up to the storks
are known as being very rigorous in
morality strictly speaking they say only
certain things are morally valuable
money is not one of the things they
consider to be morally valuable virtues
of character you know things like that
they see those as as morally valuable
they do think here's where it gets kind
of interests
they do think that human beings are
motivated by self-interest but then at a
certain point our self-interest should
give way in the sense of just you know
exclusionary self-interest my
self-interest as opposed to yours if we
really are going to realize human
potential we need to understand that we
are social beings and that behaving a
purely individualistic way is going to
hurt and damage other beings and that we
have to actually say no to ourselves to
some of our desires at certain points we
have the capacity to develop something
more than just you know egoism you might
say fully fully rational life they also
talk about these virtues of character
wisdom justice temperance and courage
yeah they say that these are what's
really good their opposites are what's
really bad those are pretty hard to live
up to there's a very interesting
discussion in a book called on duties
between two stoic scholars about things
like pricing they got down to the really
nitty-gritty when it came to some of
these things pricing is that you have to
reveal to a customer that your prices
are not the best prices or not now the
Stoics actually disagreed about this
they hashed out there are their
discussions based on a lot of different
principles another key stoic idea in
ethics that might make it seem a little
bit tougher to live up to is this notion
of duty we have duties that are revealed
to us by the relationships and the roles
of some some of the duties we have a
sort of universal like don't don't steal
other people's stuff some of them have
to do with our particular relationship
so for example I'm I'm the speaker right
so when I come in what should I do
that's a baseline right is there any
particular way in which I should speak
or should I just get up and say random
stuff that okay take up your your hour
with I just come in and tell you
something
I was a student we used ok look at me
what's what's wrong with this guy
doesn't he understand that here's how I
should be well you can say the same
thing about the owner of a company the
owner of a company has certain duties in
relation to who just himself or herself
screw the world I get to do what I want
I have my own company
how long is to him business doing that
li who do you abused who do you have
relationships with customers ok so two
very important groups anybody who's
working for you anybody who's buying
your product suppliers probably right if
you have if you get big enough you have
shareholders the outside community
perhaps what we call stakeholders all of
these are things that stoic can take
very seriously stomach would say it
doesn't matter if other people in the
industry are behaving bad and not
fulfilling their duties you still have
to fulfill your duties if you want to
live up to the stoic life the stomach's
also viewed the human being as being
part of a larger community being part of
ultimately a world order so you know
just just focusing only on your little
community and to the detriment to the
rest of the world probably not something
Stoics could get behind so they would be
thinking global terms so here's a
question that we can we can kind of end
with and I hope it provokes a little bit
of discussion would with what I've
presented so far would being fully
stomach get in the way of effectiveness
in terms of leadership or in terms of
being an entrepreneur would it keep you
from being able to be the best leader or
the best entrepreneur possible so that
maybe even while we go this far with
stoicism and then that other stuff leave
that leave that aside that's just for
the professor
self-help people or you know but but in
a business context just this stuff so
you know for the Stoics when I make it
even more difficult the only people who
truly deserve to be called leaders are
the people who are actually ethical so
Julius Caesar would not be a leader
Julius Caesar would be a tyrant for the
stars quite a few CEOs would not be
genuine leaders even though they they
call the shots for sometimes hundreds of
thousands of people what matters is what
we do at the exercise of power or
authority and it wouldn't just be ethics
in terms of compliance or due diligence
just no meeting the bare minimum it
would be cultivating these virtues and
if you're you know if you were say a CEO
presumably it wouldn't just be you don't
want to screw your employees over or
raise their expectations too high you
would want to promote the good life for
them doesn't mean that you wouldn't make
them all Stoics right although you might
hand out notebooks you know read this
book by epictetus or something like that
that the parties so that's something to
think about in terms of leaders what
about entrepreneurs presumably some of
you want to be entrepreneurs we got this
great senate friend alex and
entrepreneurship you want to have your
own business someday right what makes an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is it just
having a product we're finding customers
so you're shaking and what else like
what wow that's important yeah okay
yeah that's one of the sad truths of
like trying to innovate right this you
know get a lot of support do you have
any duties in relation to other people
why should they buy your product as
opposed to other competitors there's the
key yeah you should be aiming to provide
something good to somebody else right
something that they're not getting from
somebody else that's why innovation
matters otherwise who cares innovate all
you like if all you're doing is
generating you know 68 new kinds of
colored crap
it doesn't matter but if you're
providing something that genuinely
improves people's lives now that's part
of what's at the core of being an
entrepreneur and the question then that
I leave you with is well would stoicism
help them or would it get in the way
well given what you know so far what
would you say
I'm curious very curious to know what
you guys think about this because I know
what I think well I'm not that
interested in what I think what do you
have so okay that's important concern
long-term sustainable we say growth
sooner or later over the long term that
seems to be the case what are the rest
of you think so something that you are
not worried about sounds nice dr. bean
it's so exciting to care if you don't
read them I can tell you that if they
did they wouldn't be good stones what do
you think
okay
yeah it certainly it offers a lot of
resources for that well any other
questions since we're almost out of time
concerns comments if you do have any
notice my email is at the bottom I'm
happy to talk more about this is a lot
to process I think but thanks very much
for your time and attention
[Applause]